what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and welcome to episode 2 of
askgaryvee yan asks how do i create
interesting content for a boring subject
such as a hardware store any ideas
thanks yan a hardware store is very far
from boring I mean we've talked to
people that are asking about highways
and cement and all sorts of things and I
have no idea how you think that a
hardware store is boring when you're
selling tools something that tons and I
mean tons of people are actually
passionate about so you know the fact
that you've categorized it as boring
makes me say we have to work on your
mindset because you need to open it up
because construction and homes and dy I
do it yourself all these things are
happening right now and I would argue
that a bunch of people who are watching
right now we're going to leave comments
in YouTube saying that is far from
boring so I would say it's not boring
the content is quite easy and get your
ass to it
Eric asks need your advice on getting
the first 10 customers for a creative
service startup we make product videos
for online retailers Eric I once made a
video and let's link this up it down
here below and let's put it up right
here can you guys make another video
move in here is there just gonna be a
still shot yeah if it's on YouTube we
can make it look beautiful the famous
video I made where I cold call people
for customers right and it was something
people really loved then that's my
answer to get the first 10 customers you
have to grind
sorry Darach and I screwed up your but
you have to grind what I mean by
grinding is you have to just reach out
to every single person like you just
have to roll up on people I mean like
hey will you buy my stuff there was one
customer so I was awesome did you catch
her in the background or no I mean you
just have to ask so go to every single
per
in the world that will possibly buy your
thing and ask them to buy your thing
will asks I'm taught in marketing that
people are basically sheep what does
that say about your idea that the
consumer decides well I don't know who's
teaching you this some university or
some douchebag marketers but you know
I'm there's truth in that we can
influence
I mean marketing clearly influences but
the customers own preconceived notions
and DNA and the way they grew up and all
the other variables are a factor as well
and they get to choose at the end of the
day we're not hypnotizing people there's
not some weird thing floating above my
head that's saying buy my book you know
you need to get into post edit on that
right you know that's not happening
and so you know I think that is a very
all-in 100% way to look at it do I think
marketing influences people of course do
I think we're hypnotizing people no yes
he's back draaga asks I'm an indie music
producer what tips do you have to
program my content using social media
marketing dragga what's up your back and
I respect that you're an episode 1 & 2
you one day will be a trivia question so
the question is look you're an indie guy
you're trying to promote I'm actually
gonna move the mic to Steve he's not
even expecting this go there go there do
you the sound or you're good with
something you don't know the cameras got
its own sound yeah go ahead
saying what you just said to me so Tyga
I looked at your Twitter account and you
posted a remix of a Rihanna track eight
times in the last 24 hours since we
aired the last episode of the show
actually that's a little bit
overwhelming dragon now couple things I
think the thing to really think about is
listening I was actually clicking and so
I've got focused I don't know what he
was doing everybody was replying to
somebody I like the replying in Twitter
that's a tactic look here's here's what
I think it's all about the quality of
the music matters
building up your soundcloud matters how
does one do that one of the ways to
really do that is to become old-school
in some ways believe it or not I'm going
to go left-field on you how about some
music
message boards but not spamming them
becoming a part of that community
how about searching every single person
that tweeted about Rihanna Steve pull it
up every single person who tweeted about
Rihanna let me guess but I'm going to
think it's a shitload right and so in
that shitload jumping in and engaging
with those people now you got to spend a
lot of time you decided to do a Rihanna
remix not me
so that means you've got to go through
it and it's gonna take you a couple
hours because everybody's be tweeting
like Rihanna's hot [ __ ] Rihanna all that
stuff and you have to find people that
are actually talking about Rihanna's
music which I don't know probably small
percentage of what's going on on Twitter
you've got to jump into that and engage
with it authentically engaging and
you've heard the 19 year old dude move
is not saying check out my track you've
got to just kind of you know jam with
people I would recommend if you're
jamming people and jamming with people
not jamming if you're jamming with
people during that period changing the
URL in your Twitter profile to be a
direct link to the Rihanna track that's
right folks that was a tactic and that's
why I asked Gary Vee is going to be a
big time show if you're deciding to do
something specific for a two-day period
like draaga should around engaging
people around Rihanna's music that
actually talk about the music I
recommend he changes his Twitter
profiles URL from his probably homepage
or whatever he's got going on to the
actual link to the SoundCloud of that
show because while he's engaging people
gonna be like who the hell's draaga let
me click this link in his URL boom
they're listening to that the viral loop
gets going the viral loop gets going
Justin asks where are the best places
for hiring great employees in States
what's your process
ah the best places to hire great
employees is actually this is kind of
like the honey and bees thing my process
is a little bit different I'm actively
running a social and digital agency and
I am at the lucky stage of my career
where I'm in own personality in that and
on public speaking I'm doing the
askgaryvee show
plug and you know it's coming to us
right I'm at that place now so that's
not practical for the far majority of
people watching this and because I want
this to be practical I would say what I
would think is very simply the best
tactic for all of you watching who want
to hire good people is to search the key
terms on Twitter search that are talking
about the things that you do for a
living and then doing the homework the
dirty little secret is my friends is
most people don't want to work you know
easy it is to find good employees let me
explain you go to Twitter search you
search the terms around the job
description that you want not the job
description terms but the kind of things
they be doing looking at people talking
about design websites design forums
design aspects and then looking around
what people are saying then clicking on
their profile clicking their homepage
probably landing under the stein
portfolio finding for people that you
think do a good job emailing them or
tweeting at them saying do you want to
interview for a job are you looking for
a job three of them four say no one says
yes the other three give you four
referrals that are kind of like them
you've got five people interview and you
hire one of those people but that just
took eight hours didn't it and that my
friends is how you actually do it
because everybody's looking for quick
tactics to make it easy and putting in
the work always always matters you with
a little bit of me we're changing the QA
world
you